non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans face
aux territoires une émission de
télévision à la fois à la télévision
bien sûr en direct chaque jeudi à 9h30
et en même temps sur le numérique c'est
une émission cross-média face aux
territoires c'est donc en direct sur tv5
monde chaque jeudi c'est 403 millions de
foyers 200 pays quatorze langues et en
direct sur les plates formes de ouest
france.fr de nicematin.fr de var-matin
point fr et de notre partenaire
également france antilles en léger
différé pour des raisons locales bonjour
xavier bertrand merci d'être notre
premier invité de cette nouvelle formule
face aux territoires le titre dit tout
de l'émission vous êtes président de la
région de france et vous êtes bien sûr
nul ne l'ignorent candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
xavier bertrand une actualité après
l'intervention des manuels macron et à
la veille de plusieurs manifestations
qui se profile ce week-end regroupant
des gens des citoyens de plus en plus
hostile à la vaccination on les appelle
d'ailleurs ils ont déjà un nom un surnom
les anti vaccin au moment où plusieurs
scientifiques des médecins explique
qu'il va falloir une troisième dose de
vaccin pour combattre combattre les
nouveaux variants car il y en aura
plusieurs on le sait mais est ce qu'il y
à un risque de coupure de fracture entre
les gens de gilet jaune isation de la
situation est ce que la société
française est prête aujourd'hui à
affronter cela il ya encore des appels à
manifester dès ce week-end notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux la france est un
pays fracturé depuis longtemps et
l'enjeu des responsables politiques de
tous et bien évidemment du présent de la
république c'est de réduire ses
fractures c'est d'apaiser le pays mais
en attendant on parle de la crise
sanitaire la seule façon de terrasser la
coville est la seule façon de reprendre
une vie normale la seule façon de sauver
des vies et d'éviter des malades c'est
la vaccination
il n'y en a pas d'autre et je n'ai pas
entendu d'ailleurs de propositions de
mesures alternatives de la part de qui
que ce soit donc les décisions sont
difficiles je les ai appelés de mes
voeux depuis déjà bien dans donc
aujourd'hui s'il n'y a pas la
vaccination
on va rester dans ce tunnel avec aussi
les malades et aussi des drames est ce
que vous arrivez le ton du président de
la république dans son allocution est-ce
que vous soutenez à fond emmanuel macron
dans cette affaire je les dis voilà
quelques jours au nom de la cohérence
j'ai toujours la même position et
notamment sur l'extension du pass
sanitaires je sais aussi qu'il ya
toujours plus efficace que contraindre
ces convaincre mais en attendant au
moment où nous sommes il nous faut
absolument qu'il y ait un maximum de
vaccination alors je me mets aussi à la
place de toutes celles et ceux qui
attendaient encore en se disant je n'ai
pas été malades attendent encore un peu
et qu'il a au moment des vacances voient
tous leurs plans complètement modifié et
qui doivent s'organiser c'était la
question notamment des adolescents c'est
la question de la restauration c'est le
monde de la culture qui attendait on va
pas recommencer le deux poids deux
mesures laissez-nous nous adapter et
tout ça montre bien également que quand
on prend une décision au sommet de
l'état on doit penser aussitôt à la mise
en oeuvre savez la politique comme
l'économie comme tout si c'est pas
hauteur des hommes et les femmes ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça devrait
fonctionner mais en attendant de juin
sur le gouvenement été à la hauteur dans
cette affaire précisément viens de vous
le dire je viens de vous le dire très
bien je viens de vous dire je suis un
opposant
c'est vrai mais quand il ya des
décisions d'intérêt général où il s'agit
de protéger nos concitoyens
là il doit pas y avoir d'hésitation
c'est aussi l'ancien ministre de la
santé qui parle j'avais bien suis
conscient et c'est vrai quand on a été
ministre de la santé un jour on mesure
peut-être plus encore que d'autres ce
besoin impératif de protéger de sauver
des vies on passe à la première partie
de cette émission dans un instant
première partie avec françois-xavier
lefranc bonjour j'aurais xavier le franc
bonjour vous êtes directeur en chef de
ouest france le premier quotidien
francophone du monde nous sommes la
première chaîne francophone du monde
cette association allait aller de pair
allait de soi vous avez des questions à
poser à xavier bertrand et on commence
bien sûr sur les jeunes puisqu'il vient
d'en parler oui les jeunes parce que
neuf jeunes sur dix n'ont pas voté ne
presque neuf jeunes sur dix c'est quand
même énorme alors comment entamer le
long marathon de la campagne électorale
pour la présidentielle comment parler de
l'avenir des territoires de l'avenir de
la france quand on sait que autant de
jeunes se sentent très loin de la
politique s'ils auraient cependant en
répondant clairement à leurs
préoccupations
leurs préoccupations quotidiennes
étaient aussi leurs préoccupations pour
l'avenir
je sus père de quatre enfants et j'ai
bien conscience également que j'ai une
responsabilité en tant que père joe si
une responsabilité en tant que
responsable politique est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle beaucoup des
jeunes que j'ai rencontrés pendant cette
campagne des régionales nous disent pour
nous c'est premier emploi le premier
logement
la mobilité c'est à dire comment on fait
pour se déplacer notamment quand on
n'habite pas dans le coeur des
métropoles et il faut y apporter des
réponses concrètes c'est notamment la
raison pour laquelle notamment dans la
région on met vraiment le paquet sur
tout ce qui est formation tout ce qui
est également accès l'emploi les stages
pour leur permettre que cette première
marche soit pas infranchissable il a là
je veux encore aller plus loin notamment
au titre de la région pour 6 millions
d'habitants et si ces propositions
fonctionne comme je le pense sur ce elle
aussi que je porterai il ya aussi un
autre aspect le permis de conduire
le permis de conduire on nous dit les
jeunes sont moins intéressés par le
permis de conduire c'est pas vrai c'est
que le permis de conduire aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près 1500 euros quand vous
l'avez du premier cours c'est quasiment
un impôt qui dit pas son nom parce
qu'après le permis de conduire il ya la
voiture donc il faut des oeuvres et la
région a décidé a décidé que 90 % du
prix de ce permis serait financée par la
région pour des jeunes qui sont en
formation ou en recharge vous voyez est
le vôtre j'ai 10 ans nick le vote
électronique est ce que ce serait
d'ailleurs on est sur autre chose les
jeunes vous dise moi déjà je sais bien
que je dois trouver ma place dans la
société mais ce qu'ils veulent c'est que
ce ne soit pas une marche
infranchissable comme je disais tout à
l'heure donc ce sont des réponses
concrètes et il ya aussi autre chose
c'est aussi l'avenir c'est la question
l'écologie parce qu'ils se disent dans
dix ans dans 20 ans dans trente ans que
le réchauffement climatique si vous ne
luttez pas contre mais sur quelle
planète on va virer dans quelles
conditions on peut déclarer ses impôts
sur internet est-ce qu'il faut pas
mettre en place le vote électronique qui
résoudra pas tout parce que ça c'est une
vraie tournée sont là on est sur un fait
ce que ça me faciliterait pas les jours
je vais vous dire une chose ça marche
aux états unis xavier bertrand la
politique si elle est concrète et si
elle amène des résultats eh ben les gens
vous retourner voter et les jeunes aussi
mais à force d'entendre des politiques
qui l'oignon vous savez nous peut pas
grand-chose à fait pas grand chose c'est
l'europe c'est la finance et la
technostructure qui décide
pourquoi se déplacer pour ça mais
pardonnez moi je pense que la politique
n'est pas morte à une condition qu'elles
définissent une vision qu'elle est née
tic et surtout qu'elle amène des
résultats et le vote électronique je ne
connais rien de mieux en terme de
sécurité que se déplacer hors de chez
soi dans un bureau de vote que ce soit
papier ou électronique parce que vous
êtes à l'abri de toute pression de toute
pression et pour l'électronique moi je
veux bien mais si on a toutes les
garanties pour éviter la cyber fraude et
que les garanties cybersécurité sont
posées mais le premier point la
politique elle est concrète elle amène
des résultats les gens et les jeunes se
tourneront à nouveau vers la politique
françois-xavier lefranc vos équipes de
ouest france ont réalisé une vidéo avec
une jeune fille c'est camille d'acier et
louise saubade qui l'ont réalisé on va
écouter à une question à poser
exactement à xavier bertrand moi c'est
margot j'ai 24 ans je reprends mes
études en septembre prochain dans le
luxe et la mode si j'ai pas voter aux
régionales c'est
et parce qu'en fait je me sens pas
concerné j'arrive pas à me rendre compte
de l'impact que ça va avoir dans ma vie
dans le quotidien vous avez bertrand
tant que candidat je voulais savoir
quelles étaient vos idées pour plus
concernés les jeunes dans les élections
régionales
margot 24 ans à rennes premier emploi
premier stage premier logement est aussi
l'axé la mobilité quand ils en ont
besoin ce sont des réponses concrètes
que j'ai apporté que j'ai apportée dans
la campagne c'est pas pour autant que
les jeunes se sont massivement déplacés
dans les hauts de france mais encore une
fois si on lui montrent que la margot
c'est margot lingots que la politique au
rang de sa vie - difficile est meilleur
les gens scandent aura nourri que font
les régions mais là où il a aussi un
autre sujet pour margot il sait que le
millefeuille français politique ni dans
l'action des régions le budget des
régions françaises c'est entre 25 et 30
milliards c'est la moitié du budget de
la seule région de bavière c'est un peu
plus que la seule région de catalogne
c'est 13 fois moins que le budget de
l'état comment est ce que les régions
peuvent aujourd'hui bien travaillé avec
des budgets finalement très faible que
le prénom de la république leur fasse
confiance et qu'on aille beaucoup plus
loin en matière de transferts de
compétences au nom de l'efficacité de
l'efficacité on prend un exemple
politique d'emploi pour revenir sur ce
que disait margot les politiques
d'emploi la région des hauts de france a
les finances 60 à 70 me de formation de
demandeurs d'emploi par an pour l'emploi
pendant ce temps là on finance toujours
une partie croyez pas qu'on pourrait
plus faire plus simple est d'avoir un
pilote unique imaginez si dans une
voiture j'avais deux pilotes ça
fonctionne pas ça fonctionne pas voilà
ce que je demande très concrètement
simplification mais comme je le tiendrai
pas c'est ce que je veux proposer en
tant que président quand on regarde
l'ensemble des bus et là c'est pas vous
voyez c'est pas de la simplification une
réforme pour une réforme c'est pour plus
d'efficacité prenez la santé je demande
à ce que le pilotage des agences
régionales de santé passe sous
l'autorité dès ses résidents des
présidents de région c'est un sujet ne
l'obtiendrait pas alors je le propose
dans ce projet de terry de ce projet de
société qu'est ma république des
territoires la république des
territoires alors elle aujourd'hui est
ce qui fait que la république de
territoire c'est moins d'état c'est
mieux d'état parce que j'ai besoin d'un
état qui assure la pro section des
français la sécurité la justice la lutte
contre l'islamisme la reprise en main
notre politique migratoire la défense
nationale ça c'est à l'état de le faire
et à personne d'autre et puis il y aussi
les grandes orientations les grandes
directions de l'équité la justice c'est
à dire sur l'éducation sur la santé mais
pour le reste je veux aussi qu'il y ait
un état dans les territoires je fais 100
fois plus confiance un préfet qui
connaît la réalité que directeur
d'administration centrale le centralisme
dawson est rendu compte avec la crise du
coc vide c'est un cadavre qui nous
encombrent aujourd'hui et donc si vous
voulez un maximum d'efficacité c'est
plus de compétences pour les
collectivités locales c'est aussi plus
de pouvoirs aux préfets notamment pour
des implantations d'entreprises qu'au
niveau national et puis c'est aussi
autre chose c'est de permettre à nos
concitoyens de bien vivre là où ils sont
vous parlez gilet jaune tout à l'heure
il ya eu deux messages très forts dans
les gilets jaunes des ronds-points pas
ceux qui sont allés massacré l'arc de
triomphe et qui sont allés avec les
black blocks ceux qui n'ont jamais rien
cassé leur message était et est très
simple pour moi quand on travaille et
qu'on n'y arrive pas ça peut pas durer
et l'autre par quand on n'habite pas
dans le coeur des métropoles on n'est
pas des citoyens de seconde zone pour
autant ce que je veux également c'est
que l'on fasse à nouveau confiance au
territoire qu'on investisse massivement
dans les territoires et que l'on puisse
également permettre à ceux qui ne
veulent plus vivre dans les métropoles
de pouvoir s'installer xavier bertrand
notamment dans nos territoires c'est un
projet de société pour moi c'est pas
seulement une décentralisation pour être
un bon président de la république il
faut avoir été président de région où
d'autres expériences amères mère
également il connaît le savez il ya deux
aspects je vous disais tout à l'heure la
politique si elle n'est pas faite à
hauteur d'hommes et de femmes ça ne
fonctionne pas quand vous avez été
confrontés notamment pied d'un immeuble
à ce que vivent les résidents en termes
d'insécurité ah ça vous l'oubliez jamais
et quand vous recevez dans une
permanence quelqu'un qui porteur d'un
projet qui vous avez besoin de faciliter
la vie donc ça vous retenez également et
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui a du mal à
joindre les deux bouts en travaillant et
qui vous demande justement un coup de
main vous l'oubliez pas non plus ça je
crois que c'est très important il faut
une vision bien évidemment vous avez
aussi la question de la place de la
france dans le monde mais si vous
hommes et femmes sacem pas fonctionné
françois-xavier le franc devait un
dessinateur un collaborateur oui je n'y
joue un homme des territoires terrenoire
nom d'emmanuel gens nus qui dessine tous
les jours qui commente l'actualité dans
les sens et qui a une question ça tombe
bien on est dans une phase où l'on
regarde ce jeudi sa part à monsieur
présidents et autres france bonjour
voici ma question vous réclamer plus
d'autonomie pour votre région c'est
l'esprit girondins mais si en 2022 vous
arrivez au sommet de l'état
serez-vous l'artisan d'une nouvelle
politique de décentralisation
parce que
de l'endroit où on se situe
on n'a pas forcément le même point de
vue
mais xavier bertrand si vous y arrivez
car ce matin vous êtes venu évidemment
nous sommes en direct et vous avez eu du
mal à accéder à paris la réponse est oui
la réponse est oui c'est à dire que ce
que je dis aujourd'hui c'est ce que je
veux faire demain savez j'ai beaucoup de
défauts mais je pense pas être
incohérent et au nom de la cohérence que
je demande aujourd'hui pour un meilleur
fonctionnement du pays et je vous
l'indiquais un présent de la république
doit aussi se concentrer sur quelques
grands défis avec brio rites et amal je
ne vais pas faire je vais pas faire 200
propositions une question assez précis
liste n'est juste pour être peut être
éclairer il n'y a pas trente réformes à
faire
les français veulent quoi ils veulent
vivre en paix et en sécurité et ils
veulent vivre de leur travail et ils
aspirent ce jeu propose un nouveau
projet de société c'est cette république
des territoires voilà c'est normal c'est
justement avec ces territoires je vais
prendre l'exemple des langues régionales
ça c'est des langues régionales c'est un
sujet qui revient régulièrement depuis
des années des années dans le conseil
constitutionnel donc a retoqué une
proposition
de loi c-6 pas si le conseil
constitutionnel oui certes effectivement
les parties pour les audits par des
députés de la majorité
l'action du gouvernement c'est à dire
qu'on vote existant est ce que et
derrière le gouvernement serre la main
on recourt les shows et la naissance et
les choses n'avaient pas été réglés
avant il ya eu d'autres majorité avant à
chaque fois qu'on parle des langues
régionales on n'a pas l'impression que
c'est un sujet qui brûle les doigts est
ce que on n'a pas un état français à
l'état central un personnel politique
qui a peur en fait chaud de la diversité
française de la diversité des
territoires des cultures régionales
est-ce qu'on n'a pas quand même un grand
mouvement a lancé parce que à chaque
fois c'est la même chose on s'en occupe
tout le monde est d'accord pour les
langues régionales mais c'est un sujet
qui brûle les doigts en fait c'est pas
ça qui menace l'unité du pays
la république une et indivisible ce ne
sont pas les langues régionales qui
justement menacent cet édifice il ya
beaucoup d'autres choses qui donnent à
cet édifice la culture du wac
l'intersexualité ou là on va dresser les
français les uns contre les autres et
encore une fois c'est toujours bien
d'expliquer ce que l'on fait pour
montrer sur l'étang cohérence moi je
nous allons monter un office du flamand
je crois aussi à la place du picard
parce que c'est l'engrais halal est
l'apport de la diversité et elles
permettent aussi de respecter des
entités chacun dans quel cadre ce qu'il
faut modifier le cadre républicain
le cadre républicain mais déjà qu'on
arrête aussi de mettre un coup d'arrêt à
ce qui existe et ce qui marche
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et j'ai déjà
indiqué moi je suis prêt à aller dans ce
débat sur la reconnaissance des langues
régionales mais ce que je vous dis là je
le fais chez moi françois xavier le
franc dévié bertrand une chaîne de
télévision que vous connaissez bien vous
parlez la picardie qui s'appelle bo et
d'ombré aux picards dictant les hôtes
france à une question à vous poser c'est
anne charlotte du vivier qui en est la
rédactrice en chef on les écoute ça
concerne vos concitoyens à vous
particulièrement bon jour elle charlotte
du vivier journalistes pour wéo la
télévision en othe france
les habitants de cette région vous ont
renouvelé leur confiance et vous ont
réélu président de région alors même
qu'ils savaient que vous alliez être
candidat résidentiel pour autant
aujourd'hui beaucoup se posent la
question comment va se passer ce mandat
qui va assurer l'intérim
et surtout comment vous allez réussir
incarner cette proximité avec le
territoire ou de france et les habitants
des hauts de france que vous prenez un
en tant que président de région tout en
vous lançant dans cette campagne pour
les présidentielles en fait les journées
donc que 12 heures oui mais faut
toujours dire la vérité et moi je dis la
vérité j'ai dit la fois dernière quand
j'avais été candidat je n'accepterai
aucune autre responsabilité et même si
les propositions pu m'être fait je suis
resté à la tête de la région et là j'ai
indiqué si je suis élu à la tête de la
région je serai candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qu'est-ce que j'ai pas
entendu voilà là c'est une erreur telle
qu'on voudrait le temps tout le we la
réponse est oui oui je pourrais aussi
aller plus loin pourquoi j'ai dit les
choses parce que cette élection me donne
cette légitimité ma connaissance des
gens des enjeux c'est aussi quelque
chose qui pour moi est très très
important et cette légitimité me donne
aussi une force tout commence pour moi
dans les outrances et voyez quand on dit
la vérité aux gens bah ils vous
sanctionne pas toutes ces questions sur
les questions que j'ai entendu imposant
de beaucoup de commentateurs mais les
non c'était pas ça a c'est à dire et on
a bien conscience qu'il ya une partie
des solutions c'est la région mais une
bonne partie des solutions c'est au
sommet de l'état que ça joue
françois-xavier le front là une ouest
france aujourd'hui la new wave france et
l'europe l'international et évidemment
les territoires avec la question
climatique on la voit le plan notamment
européens et l'international parce que
la vie locale la vie des territoires
c'est aussi l'avis du monde et on ne
peut pas comprendre l'un sans l'autre
voilà donc la une de ouest france elle
exprime un petit peu tout ça et là de la
question des territoires c'est aussi la
question de l'égalité des territoires on
n'oublie pas les territoires ultramarins
parce que ça fait aussi partie des
préoccupations souvent oubliée lors et
apporte en termes de développement et
qu'on veut en parler en termes de
sécurité de nérac france antilles où les
rejoins tout à l'heure françois-xavier
le front ouest france c'est quoi la
diffusion ckoi l'impact numérique et
print et le web seront c'est un grand
média indépendant qui dépend d'ailleurs
d'une structure associative à but non
lucratif c'est une grande plateforme
numérique c'est le premier journal
francophone au monde est un journal qui
parle à des gens dans le monde entier
qui parle de la vie internationale de
l'actualité internationale et bien
évidemment des territoires de tous les
territoires sans oublier les territoires
ultramarins je tiens à le dire et c'est
le premier quotidien français est-ce que
je peux rebondir un court instant vous
avez 20 secondes ce qui montre bien
c'est qu'on peut être très ancré dans
son territoire et comprendre qu'on a
forcément un destin national et qu'on
est aussi liée à l'europe c'est pas du
tout antinomiques quand je parle des
territoires c'est pas une opposition
province paris c'est pas une opposition
métropole ruralité c'est tout simplement
un tout mais faire en sorte que chacun
se sente respecté et puis se trouver sa
place dans notre république c'est ça qui
est très important il a une montre que
tout ça n'est absolument pas
antinomiques au progrès voilà vous êtes
d'en face aux territoires la première
émission politique à la télévision et
sur le numérique avec comme partenaire
ouest france merci françois xavier le
franc vous retrouve au mois de septembre
pour la continuité de cette émission
tous les jeudis à 9 heures 30 en direct
et on peut nous voir actuellement sur
les plates formes de ouest france ouest
france.fr dans un instant denis carot
nous rejoint merci
[Applaudissements]
bonjour denis carot vous venice vous
êtes le directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin et de var matin et
vous êtes là pour parler avec xavier
bertrand jour en un jour un peu triste
puisque nous sommes au lendemain d'un
anniversaire terrible le 5e anniversaire
des as de la tarte à lucas il ya cinq
ans et 14 juillet à nice vous avez une
question d'ailleurs pour xavier bertrand
ce sujet oui on va démarrer xavier
bertrand vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
la régionalisation des politiques de
santé on a vu au coeur de la crise
sanitaire les collectivités les villes
les départements les métropoles ont été
plus réactive globalement et plus dans
l'action concrète que que l'état
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
il faut que l'état s'efface que les ars
ceux qui ont été créés il ya dix ans
disparaissent et quel va être le feu
quel doit être le fonctionnement en
mattern en matière de santé en région
qu'elle passe sous le pilotage des élus
notamment des élus régionaux et qu'en
cas de crise sanitaire elle passe sous
le pilotage des préfets les préfets sont
vraiment réactif ils connaissent le
terrain ils connaissent les élus mais
c'est pas dans le bureau d'un ministère
qu'on doit décider si sur telle ou telle
plage on va intermédiaire l'orateur à
l'égard des préfets de toujours rimé
parce que ce s'cusez moi ce sont des
représentants de l'état qui d'ailleurs
devrait représenter tout l'état c'est
pas normal que dans un territoire le
préfet se soit pas l'équivalent du
premier ministre est qu'il représente
l'état et qu'il est aussi la possibilité
d'adapter les règles nationales c'est
vrai que moi j'ai un préfet il quitte
ses fonctions donc je peux en parler
michel lalle un jeu quand je n'aurai pas
avec lui grâce à lui on a eu des
implantations d'entreprises que
l'application stricte de la
réglementation nationale ne nous aurait
pas permis d'obtenir il va partir ce
sont des milliers d'emplois pour
lesquels nous avons pu travailler
ensemble et sur l'est sur notamment sur
la santé je pense que si on veut de la
réactivité faut faire confiance aux élus
faut donner la main aux élus les gens
des ars qui se lèvent le matin ils
cherchent à faire bien mais ils sont
coincés par des directives nationales
c'est ce centralisme dont je parlais
tout à l'heure il est dépassé et
aujourd'hui ils empêchent la france
d'avancer donc vous le voyez quand je
parle des préfets je veux pas moins
d'état je peux être moins d'état à paris
dans des domaines qui ne sont pas de la
con étant stratégique de l'état mais
pour le reste qu'on fasse confiance
c'est la question de la confiance et de
la respiration qui est la clé jusque
jusqu'où pourrait aller les compétences
des prêts faits les compétences
spécifiques les compétences des préfets
c'est en matière de santé c'est en terme
de crise sanitaire de crise sanitaire et
pour le reste le pilotage la façon dont
on va mettre en place des maisons de
santé faut aller vite vous avez des
médecins qui sont prêts à s'impliquer
vous pouvez pas avoir vingt réunions et
vous pouvez pas avoir deux ans de
procédure faut aller vite et les élus
sont conscients de cette réactive a
permettra d'être plus efficace notamment
sur la question qu'on connaît tous en
région des déserts médicaux exactement
exactement mais je vous le dis les
agents de l'état ne cherche pas à mal
faire mais ils n'ont pas la liberté
d'action qu'on les éduque et les élus
surtout les élus locaux sont vraiment
conscients d'une chose nous avons une
obligation de résultat
l'efficacité est là elle a pas de
référence partisane l'efficacité cherche
à bien faire votre vision sur les
consultations
numérique par internet
vous avez souvent dénoncé dans le passé
un des premiers à dénoncer l'imam google
de dérive de l'interminable différend
certains dérivés est ce que la ss qui a
pas du bon à cela non mais attendez les
consultations numérique très bien mais
faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un derrière en
chair et en os et il faut des médecins
moi j'ai des expérimentations que c'est
un bon lanceur était l'une des premières
régions sur ces consultations numérique
mais vous ne ferez pas arrivé les gens
qui vont entrer dans une sorte de boîte
et puis derrière ça va être lu par
l'intelligence artificielle moi je veux
garder des gens en chair et en os c'est
l'une des réponses mais c'est pas la
seule c'est pas la seule et j'ai bien
l'intention dans les propositions que je
ferai à l'occasion de cet été où je vais
commencer à aller à la rencontre des
français profondeur en prenant le temps
sans forcément les médias de tester des
idées et de voir également ce que les
gens souhaitent j'ai l'image des autres
ans j'ai la connaissance de transe mais
je vois aussi dans les autres régions ça
correspond aussi à mes convictions
profondes et je faire des propositions
notamment pour ouvrir davantage de
points d'urgence notamment de services
d'urgence sur l'ensemble du territoire
ça c'est ce que nos concitoyens
attendent beaucoup franck fernandez
chez vous de nice matin est à la
rencontre d'une jeune fille à nice qui
s'appelle amina et qui a une question à
vous poser sa liberté pour l'écouter
bonjour monsieur xavier bertrand j'avais
pas la mina je suis niçoise que comptez
vous faire pour qu'un attentat comme
celui de nice ne se reproduise plus
voilà vous savez que les français vous
attendent sur la sécurité si on sur ce
besoin de sécurité
le risque zéro n'existe pas celui qui
dirait cela est un menteur je ne pourrai
pas lui faire confiance ce qui est vrai
vous parlez de l'attentât nice a fait
partie hélas des moments où on se
souvient exactement de ce que l'on
faisait quand on a appris les choses je
vous rappelle j'étais à marcq en baroeul
à ce moment précis et ça nous a tous
marqués ya une guerre qui nous est
déclarée depuis longtemps par les
islamistes par les islamistes
et dans cette guerre aux termes de cette
guerre ce sera eux ou nous alors c'est
eux qu'il faut éradiquer ça veut dire
qu'on doit avoir aucune complaisance et
on doit s'attaquer à eux en permanence
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'il n'ait
pas été déjà fait il ya beaucoup de
dispositifs y sont régulièrement
renforcée à chaque fois qu'il ya un
nouvel attentat c'est pas pour autant
que tout est appliquée qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire leurs ennemis déjà il faut
tout appliqué ça c'est la première des
choses avec force est une guerre josé
dit c'est une guerre tous ceux qui
prêchent contre la france tous ceux là
doivent être mis hors d'état de nuire et
nous devons aussi à voir avec un certain
nombre d'états dont nous pensons avec
des éléments forts à l'appui qu'ils
financent
des groupes qui sont anti france c'est
allah on doit avoir une discussion pour
leur dire maintenant c'est terminé ou
alors vous n'êtes pas des amis de la
france et encore une fois il faut
traquer tous ceux qui continuent à
préparer des attentats contre l'as et 1
auxerre on entend depuis des années oui
mais je vais vous dire une chose moi
j'ai conscience que c'est une guerre et
que ce qui est en cause qui est en jeu
c'est la france est ce que nous sommes
pourquoi sommes-nous le pays le plus
attaqués parce que nous avons ce
principe de laïcité que nous voulons
faire respecter parce qu'on est le pays
de l'universalisme on est tous ceux qui
ne leur convient pas et ils se disent qu
en abattant la france où en faisant en
sorte que les français aient peur dans
ces conditions là ils réussiront et j'ai
conscience que cette guerre là je la
mène je veux l'année pour les français
je l'amène aussi pour mes enfants j'ai
pas envie que mes enfants grandissent en
baissant la tête ou en évitant certains
quartiers qu'envoyer cette jeune milla
comment on peut accepter qu'une
adolescente soit obligé vivent reclus il
y a eu cette condamnation d'accord mais
tout simplement parce que sur les
réseaux sociaux elle a eu ses propos non
mais dans quel monde on vit on aurait pu
imaginer quel jour en france au 21ème
siècle on serait là ça veut donc dire
que le prétend la république doit être
convaincu qu'il est le chef des forces
armées aussi le chef des forces de
sécurité et qu'il doit porter ce combat
en permanence ça ne se fera pas du jour
au lendemain pas d'un claquement de
doigts mais le présent la réplique à
cette responsabilité particules et déjà
de nommer les choses j'avais versé
l'islamisme qui aujourd'hui
est notre ennemi et nous pose problème
alors on doit s'y attaquer xavier
bertrand vous avez évoqué une peine de
cinquante ans oui pour tout détenu
condamné pour terrorisme est-ce que
c'est vraiment réaliste et pourquoi ça
ne serait pas vous avez quelqu'un qui
commet un attentat terroriste
à 20 ans à 50 ans on pense qu'il n'y a
plus aucun risque cinquante ans après je
pense qu'on a davantage de chances de
protéger les français savent et je vais
très clair là dessus c'est pour ces
actes de terrorisme c'est une peine
incompressible
incompressibles parce que le terroriste
que c'est aussi au delà des victimes je
pense notamment à celle de nice et pas
seulement fanis il ya aussi notre dame
de l'assomption à nice c'est protéger
les français c'est les mettre hors
d'état de nuire oui je veux protéger les
français et à ce qu'ils nous disent que
cette mesure est dure est-ce qu'il faut
vous les autres xavier bertrand doit
continuer à à être faible non je ne veux
pas de cette faiblesse il ya beaucoup de
pays qui ont réussi parce qu'ils ont été
dures face à ceux qui nous veulent du
mal la présence d'eric zemmour
potentiellement dans la campagne
électorale présidentielle
vous en pensez quoi rien
c'est quoi c'est un commentateur c'est
un acteur politique des anciens premiers
ministres deviennent qu'il prédit
toryali ski après une solitude comme
manuel valls qu'il prenne ses
responsabilités les français regarderont
qui clairement est capable de proposer
des solutions à leurs problèmes et
dessiner un meilleur avenir pour le pays
manuel valls chroniqueur d'une grande
chaîne d'info je suis pas comme andré
simard ministre juppé commentateurs mais
vous en pensez quoi tant que citoyen je
sais ce que je pense de manuel valls
c'est le premier ministre et ministre de
l'intérieur courageux et cette attaque à
l'islamisme et depuis des années et des
années voilà ce que je retiens de ce que
j'ai envie de dire principalement de
manuel valls denis carot quelqu'un
d'autre dans votre groupe qui s'appelle
cyril boutiques et directeur des
rédactions du groupe france antilles
partenaires de cette émission nous
n'oublions pas les territoires
d'outre-mer xavier bertrand vous en avez
parlé au démarrage de cette émission à
une question à vous poser en amp aix en
duplex depuis la martinique depuis
fort-de-france on écoute bonjour cyril
boutier directeur éditorial de france
antilles et de france-guyane xavier
bertrand les territoires ce sont aussi
les outre-mer
quelle place leur donnerez vous dans
votre campagne présidentielle comment
comptez vous répondre aux attentes des
habitants singulièrement aux antilles et
en guyane
c'est la même logique
vivre en paix en sécurité
or on sait bien que les questions de
sécurité dans nombre de territoires
d'outre-mer ne sont pas de ces garanties
et c'est aussi vivre de leur travail si
la question du développement économique
en n'oubliant pas alors c'est vrai quand
j'étais ministre ministre la sentait
ministre du travail surtout ministre de
la santé j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
outre mer ce qu'il y a eu notamment la
réunion cette crise terrible du
chikungunya on a réussi vite avec le
concours des populations locales des
élus à éradiquer le chikungunya et je
sais que pour les outremers ya quand
même cette idée à loin des yeux loin du
coeur quand je vous disais justement que
cette politique des territoires cette
république des territoires
elle comptera bien s'appuyer sur
l'outre-mer je me rendrai bien
évidemment dans les outre-mer pendant
cette campagne mais je sais que pour moi
ça tient une place bien particulière
c'est pas la même france sans les outre
mer c'est aussi un réservoir de voix
politiquement oui enfin si vous regardez
les résultats je pense que celui qui
s'attache uniquement à la question des
niches électorale celui-là n'a rien
compris ils méritent pas d'être
président de la république la vraie
question c'est de savoir si tout cela
fait partie de cette république une et
indivisible pour moi la réponse est oui
anthony caro la une de nice mme à la une
de nice matin mais c'est l'hommage à
paris et à nice 5 ans après l'attentât
avec à la fois la venue de jean castex à
nice hier après midi mais aussi la
police municipale de nice qui a défilé
pour la première fois une police
municipale défilé sur les champs elysées
pour le 14 juillet c'était en
remerciement pour son action puisque
c'est la police municipale qui a
neutralisé le terroriste de la basilique
de nice lille ce matin en deux mots
plateforme et diffusion nice matin mais
le premier média du sud-est avec une
audience lecteurs de 500 mille lecteurs
de 18 millions de visiteurs et des
formats de plus en plus diversifiées je
vous invite notamment à aller voir le
long format vidéo convient de faire
justement sur la promenade des anglais
cinq ans après il avait bertrand vous me
disiez que vous avez un attachement
particulier à la méditerranée que vous
avez loyers cette mère oui j'ai
une partie des vacances ça comment ça
finit toujours par les hôtes france mais
il ya aussi à la fois la côte d'azur et
la corse l'île rousse et l'accord sur la
balagne la balagne j'aime j'aime
passionnément la corse ce mariage qui
lie à en balagne entre la montagne et la
mer et c'est vrai que tout les toutes
les mers et les océans sont beaux même
la méditerranée veut c'est le résonance
particulière la balagne qui est touché
par des obus oui ok oui d'obtenir carros
a fait merci et des premières mesures
c'est vrai rendez-vous ans celle qui
montre bien que ce danger il est loin
d'être éradiquée qu'on a besoin de se
protéger au maximum
denis carot rendez vous en septembre
donc chaque jeudi en direct à 9h30 je
rappelle que face aux territoires et
diffusée sur les plateformes numériques
et donc les sites de nicematin.fr et de
var-matin point fr dans un instant yves
bigot nous rejoint sur ce plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bigot vous êtes le directeur générale de
tv5 monde
bonjour que sept jours troisième chaîne
en termes de diffusion mondiale après
mtv et cnn donc 200 pays 14 à 403
millions de foyers maintenant et vous
avez évidemment des questions pour
quelqu'un qui aspire à devenir président
de la république des questions
internationales bonjour xavier bertrand
le 24 avril au soir si vous êtes
président de la république vous allez
avoir du boulot mais pas seulement suis
là puisque vous hériterez pour deux mois
et une semaine de la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne
or l'europe il ya des tas de choses
formidables mais
ça manque de discipline on voit
aujourd'hui que la hongrie la pologne
même vos voisins flamands n'applique pas
les réglementations européennes
donc quelle est votre vision si vous
êtes le futur président de l'union
européenne j'aurai l'occasion à
l'automne nous présenter ma vision de
l'union européenne et j'ai eu l'occasion
notamment de m'en expliquer d'en parler
en détail avec armin laschet tu qui vous
savez qui est le candidat qui est le
ministres présidents des länder
important très important elle anime et
fally et qui jumelé les qui est candidat
à la chancellerie comme successeur
d'angela merkel bon déjà il n'est pas
question d'avoir un directoire de
l'europe mais sans l amitié franco
allemande l'europe ne pourra pas avancer
ne pourra pas fonctionner mais il faut
aussi qu'on se mette d'accord sur ce que
sont nos vrais points de convergence et
nos divergences or aujourd'hui sur
l'europe on continue à avancer mais
j'aimerais qu'on tire toutes les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé avec le break site
est pas parce que les anglais sont
toujours un peu à part qu'ils ont eu une
position très à part un pied dedans un
pied en dehors dans l'europe c'est quand
même une nation européenne la plus parmi
les plus importantes qui a quitté
l'europe et donc on doit se poser des
questions sur l'avenir européen est ce
qu on est bien d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut une taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'europe pour appliquer en matière de
commerce international
la réciprocité mais pays sont durs avec
nous pour qu'on puisse commercer et nous
on les laisse rentrer non faut arrêter
la naïveté est ce qu on est bien
d'accord là dessus est ce qu'on est bien
d'accord là dessus sur la question
énergétique sur la question de la
défense tient la défense encore une fois
que nos amis allemands le char charcot
main avance bien les allemands le
pilotage on joue le jeu mais l'avion du
futur est ce que c'est le cas la réponse
est non sur la turquie sur la question
notamment de la politique migratoire est
politique migratoire aux frontières de
l'europe il ya frontex est ce qu'on
accepte de développer encore plus les
moyens de frontex voyez sur toutes ces
questions très concrètes et qui touche
en partie au climat commerce
international aux intérêts stratégiques
l'énergie la défense et aussi sur la
question migratoire est ce qu'on est
d'accord tous ensemble ou est-ce qu'on
doit se mettre d'accord justement
quelques-uns pour tout entraîné sur ces
questions là que je mette sur la table
parce que on a beaucoup parlé des
territoires profondément attaché à mon
pays mais si on veut peser par rapport à
la chine par rapport aux états unis
c'est l'europe mais on croit encore à
l'europe puissance moi je veux bien y
croire à une condition c'est que la
souveraineté nationale ne disparaissent
pas xavier bertrand vous avez été très
en pointe dans le combat pour les
pêcheurs en tant que président d
outrance face à l'angleterre et au break
site c'est un accord qui sera révisée
est révisable l'accord actuel il ya un
risque que reviennent les problèmes
qu'on a connu non mais attendez c'est
tout de suite qu'il faut le réviser si
le royaume uni très ami avec les anglais
n'est pas parce que ma région et
voisines mais ils respectent pas les
règles si on le sert bien souvent tout
ce qui est à eux et à eux tout ce qui
est à nous se négocie donc au bout d'un
moment on a un système c'est que la
naïveté terminée terminé donc
aujourd'hui il ne délivre pas les
licences aux pêcheurs comme prévu comme
promis nous remettons en cause dès
maintenant l'accord dans ces conditions
là et il y a tellement de dossiers qui
sont en discussion que nous mettons tout
dans la balance on a aujourd'hui des
pêcheurs pas seulement dans les autres
france dans les différentes régions de
france qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent plus
travailler comme avant tout simplement
parce que l'accord n'est pas respecté
par les anglais donc c'est tout de suite
qu'il faut changer cela et pas attendre
des années qu'ils aient disparu moi je
tiens les pêcheurs parce que derrière
les pêcheurs et toute la transformation
et toute une industrie et puis encore
une fois la parole les écrits s'engage
autrement faut pas s'étonner que la
politique soit considérée comme quelque
chose de secondaire c'est pas ma
conception je me battrai pour démontrer
le contraire il faut des résultats
xavier bertrand vous êtes sur la chaîne
de la francophonie en ce moment depuis
l'assassinât de samuel paty et les
diatribes du président turc recep
erdogan contre la france il ya des
tensions dans le monde musulman et un
sentiment anti français et pas
uniquement le maghreb où le monde
musulman méditerranéen puisque c'est
aller jusqu'à des manifestations très
importantes
au sénégal pays très ami de la france
par ailleurs donc comment est ce que
vous voyez les relations que la france
doit avoir avec le monde musulman qui
n'a pas de lien
évident politiques en tous les cas avec
l'islamisme déjà que ce soir dit
clairement en ce qui me concerne mon
combat contre l'islamisme est totale
mais je ne confonds pas les musulmans et
les islamistes et je pense que le dire
et le redire et que notre politique
montre bien que jamais nous le ferons
cette confusion c'est très important a
rappelé mais vous je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure vous avez certainement entendu
je pense qu' il faut aussi comprendre
que nous sommes le pays le plus attaqué
pour ce que nous représentons et que
nous avons pas le droit le devoir de
nous défendre et tous nos amis en
afrique ou ailleurs doivent le
comprendre mais attention jamais de
confusion jamais d' amalgame entre
musulmans et islamistes jamais
l'opération barkan qui prend fin le
président de la république a annoncé un
retrait partiel qui deviendra presque
totale bientôt vous êtes favorable
soutenez le président de république en
se maintenant c'est la décision cette
phase est la décision qu'il faut prendre
maintenant je pense que l'europe aurait
dû s'impliquer plus tôt beaucoup plus
fort et de bien comprendre aussi
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ne s'agissait
pas seulement en allant combattre là bas
de protéger ce pays cette partie de
l'afrique mais c'était aussi de se
protéger nous et que nous devons aussi
veiller à ce que ce ne se reconstitue
pas des forces qui à partir de leur
territoire pourrait à nouveau projeté
des attentats mais là encore une fois la
france et de responsabilité particulière
une histoire particulière avec l'afrique
je pense qu'il va falloir aussi réécrire
cette politique parce que plus que les
chinois plus que les américains
je pense qu'on a une histoire forte à
partager et je reste intimement
convaincu vous me parler d'europe
excusez moi mais je suis aussi cette
idée c'est qu'il y ait un nouveau pacte
de développement avec l'afrique apportés
par l'europe avec l'afrique et pas
seulement sur la question migratoire sur
la question du réchauffement climatique
de l'accès à l'énergie c'est le projet
de jean louis borloo et ça je pense que
la france doit porter ça au niveau
européen train pour qu'on n'ait pas une
politique de coopération europe afrique
mais un nouveau pacte de développement
et de paix xavier bertrand vous êtes
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que ça fait l'objet de débats
dans votre famille vous disiez vous avez
quatre enfants est ce que tout le monde
et est mobilisée comment ça se passe
dans une famille quand on décide de cet
acte incroyable dans la vie d'un homme
d'être candidat à la tête de son pays
comment elle a pris votre famille je
pense que ça fait ça fait longtemps
famille c'est que je j'aime la politique
passionnément j'en fais depuis que j'ai
à 16 ans puis les 16 ans
cette ambition cette idée détermination
être président de la république ça fait
pas par contre n'y ait ni 30 ans ni 20
ans plus jeune j'avais d'autres d'autres
passions que la politique et poster dans
ma chambre c'était des joueurs de foot
michel platini johan cruyff pas par
exemple et donc j'étais pas de ceux qui
représentent la république pas du tout
mais je pense que je levier pado laisse
en vous rasant tous les matins on y
pense avoir vous rajoute pas déjà quand
vous êtes adolescents encore yves bigot
où il a regardé
mais mais je pense que cette ces
déterminations cette conviction ils
l'acceptent tellement un peu plus
compliqué pour les pour les adolescents
j'ai des jumeaux qui ont un peu plus de
14 ans pour eux c'est un peu plus
compliqué j'entends bien mais c'est vrai
vous avez raison c'est un choix qui est
personnel mais c'est aussi au bout d'un
moment des contraintes familiales mais
chacun est conscient que ma
détermination est totale merci beaucoup
xavier mérand d'avoir été le premier
invité de face aux territoires on se
retrouve au mois de septembre tous les
jeudis à 9 heures 30 en direct sur tv5
monde il bigot merci à ouest france et
nice matin ainsi qu'un france antilles
merci à nicolas renard pascal quentin
véronique rosen vague à thierry
barbedette aussi de télé 70 villes qui a
coordonné l'action des télévisions
locales dans cette affaire et à claude
périer le pdg de france antilles merci
bertrand merci à vous et bonne et et
avoue studieux d'après ce qu'on a
compris au revoir à tout ça très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]